now that you're going back to work
I mean how do you feel
there are going to be times where I will
have to work late or I may have to pick
up a week and night shift
I don't want one Amboy like midnight
stuff it's no but inventory isn't like
midnight and if gosh forbid I do need to
pick up a Friday shift it is going to be
a midnight one o'clock A.M shift like it
is what it is I'm not gonna understand
it I don't want you working till 1am
I'm sorry I don't and I'm never going to
be okay with that it's a restaurant I
can't just work days
it's just the industry and you've told
me oh my God somebody wanted to go get a
drink
I'd rather
you and I have a drink on our sofa
snuggling I want you to want that
the concerns I have
with Liz working late the people that
she works with it's young adult kids
that are still in school and they're
there to make money and party in excess
and in the past it was hard for me
because Liz's co-workers didn't like me
and they would be whispering in her hear
about our relationship
and I think that led to
our breaking up
I don't want to do that like I don't
want that to begin
you'll be okay with that
it's my job it's my title there but I'm
what you say goes
so I don't don't sound it like that
well I don't want to walk away from this
conversation unless you feel good
and like you've been heard
I'm walking away because it's just not
worth fighting about I'm going back to
work I'm making my paycheck and I'm
following your terms
our terms
your turns
okay
[Music]
if I have any chance of contributing to
a house or potentially taking on my
daughter
I need to be able to prove that I can
provide I cannot be held back and Ed
seems to be putting his own insecurities
ahead of mine and that makes me worried
about the future and Edge resistance is
making me feel like I have to choose
between him
or my job
I need a partner
[Music]
[Music]